[Musik]
hey meine lieben heute gibt es meine
baby shower torte nicht schon nicht
falls sie jetzt jeder frage instagram
hage schon gesagt ich mache baby
schritte und alle sagen du glück wurden
nein das ist für unsere nicht die ist
vor einigen monaten auf die welt
gekommen schön gesund und munter und da
gibt's jetzt bald eine große feier da
kommen 150 bis 200 gäste und deshalb
wird diese baby shower torte heute drei
stücke ich es wird nicht jeder ein
großes stück von essen aber jeder so
etwas kleines abbekommen daher fange ich
jetzt hier an mit der untersten etage
kann es sorge ich schreibe euch alles
wichtige in die video beschreibung die
genauen mengenangaben die rezepte zu
meinen basics alles in der video
beschreibung unter dem titel
und wie gesagt ist das jetzt hier meinen
saftiger schokoladen boden er eignet
sich perfekt für torten wo oben drüber
noch im gewicht drauf kommt wie bei uns
jetzt also die unterste etage soll
stabil sein
die schneide ich jetzt gleich durch mit
meiner torten täglich hier kennt er von
mir die echte klinge da kann euch nichts
kaputtgehen
alles bleibt schön geschmeidig nicht
zutiefst und dann total schön gerade und
das ganze gefühl was ist befüllen ich
bestreite es mit aprikosen konfitüre die
ich jetzt einfach auf dem herd erwärmt
habe
das heißt es hat erinnert so ein
bisschen an sachertorte und damit
starten wir jetzt
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt ganz auf die torte also
einmal auf die oberfläche und an den
rand man macht immer zwei schichten die
erste schicht die der krümel bindung
weil das ja wirklich schon noch sehr
krümmel
auch wenn ich den boden gestern
vorgebacken habe und die zweite schicht
ist einfach damit alles richtig schön
aalglatt ist und man braucht auch ghanas
oder eine art buttercreme damit der von
dann später nicht durchweicht da gibt es
ganz spezielle cremes man benutzen darf
und da haltet ihr euch am besten dran
weil sonst wenn ihr eine zu feuchte
creme habt dann würde euch der von land
später auf weichen soll ich hab jetzt
die zeit danach
ich habe gerade auch ein bisschen das
habt ihr gesehen auch mein keyboard
gemacht das dient dann als kleber und
hier auch wieder die ganz genauen
mengenangaben schreibe ich euch wieder
in die infobox und jetzt beginnt erstmal
mit der schicht für die krümel bindung
[Musik]
so das ist jetzt nur grob eingestrichen
wie gesagt erst mal nur die das grobe
die krümel bindung und jetzt gebe ich
meine torte für 20 minuten in den
kühlschrank damit die oberfläche richtig
schön fest wird und dann kommt die
zweite schicht und die muss richtig
schön ordentlich sein also bis gleich
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich die torte noch mal
richtig schön glaubt eingestrichen von
allen seiten und die zweite schicht wird
auch ein bisschen schneller fest weil
die reben im kühlschrank war und ich
gehe jetzt mal kurz runter
ich lasse sie persönlich bei
zimmertemperatur stehen wenn man sich
gerade hochsommer haben und noch weiter
mit der mittleren torte und das zeige
ich euch gleich auch so bevor ich jetzt
meinen boden durchschneide mache ich
jetzt mit creme und die creme benutzt
sich für die mittlere etage also für die
zweite und für die dritte die oberste
etage und jetzt darf es ruhig ein creme
sein die ein bisschen weicher ist nicht
zu weit ich würde es keine komplette
sahne creme dem ich habe einen großteil
mascarpone ist ja sehr fest und da gehe
ich jetzt ein bisschen sahne dazu das
habe ich hier schon vorhanden sind kalt
dann funktioniert das gleiche auch mit
dem rühren und das ist so easy leute
gäbe hier alles rein in die
küchenmaschine könnt ihr euer
handrührgerät benutzen wenn jetzt keine
da habt da geb ich noch puderzucker
natürlich für die süße dazu könnte doch
kristallzucker nehme aber der löst sich
eben schneller auf dann vanille extrakt
für den geschmack dann könnt ihr
entscheiden ob die früchte rein tut er
was ich rein gebe das zeige ich euch
gleich ich fange jetzt erstmal an das
langsam zu verhindern verbindet sich das
und dann werde ich immer schneller und
lasse seine fest ein riesengroßes
komplett steif ist da war so eineinhalb
minuten also nicht lange
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich schon mal ein drittel der
creme extra schon mal zur seite gelegt
weil ich mache mir jetzt nicht die
arbeit und machen noch eine dritte creme
weil diese klemmte die super variieren
das was ich mit kratzer seite gelegt
habe das brauche ich für die oberste
etage
da kommt dann der andere frucht rein und
hier habe ich jetzt gerade mandarin
rhein gegeben und deshalb ist diese
creme ist auch fertig ganz kurz an die
seite legen
und hier habe ich ja jetzt diesmal
hellen worden ich wollte ein bisschen
abwechslung rein bringen das ist ein
heller bis red bull mit vanille und das
werde ich den tschuldigung werde ich
jetzt auch durchschneiden diesmal
endziel böden stellt das so ein was die
immer alle gleich hoch sind und am ende
ist auch noch ein tipp von mir am ende
dazu dass die höhen alle identisch sind
das sieht dann meiner meinung nach immer
am schönsten aus
so diese etage befülle ich ja mit der
sahne creme und die dafür wie ihr wisst
nicht in kontakt zum vom land kommen und
daher gibt diesmal einen gamma spring
ich habe diesmal weiße ganache genommen
und da spielt sich einfach einen ring
außen herum wer hilft euch den
tortenring damit das ganze schön fest
ist eine wand habe und dann einfach die
sahne creme einfüllen und mit dem
nächsten boden ab schießen und dann
machen wir immer so weiter bis wir keine
würde mehr übrig haben
[Musik]
der erste schritt ist getan die krümel
bindung jetzt sie dafür 20 minuten in
den kühlschrank und dann einmal richtig
schön ordentlich verstreichen
[Musik]
so die mittlere etage ist somit auch
fertig eingestrichen und jetzt geht es
weiter mit der letzten und das ist die
kleinste etage und die mache ich nach
dem gleichen prinzip wie auch die
mittlere
[Musik]
und somit ist die dritte etage auch
fertig und jetzt geht es ja eigentlich
anders spannende nämlich ans dekorieren
und ich habe mir zu folgendes überlegt
also die farben soll richtig zeit seien
deswegen habe ich hier schon mal von
dann in ganz zart und rosa ein gefährt
das gerät plötzlich die kamera erkennt
es aber extrem hart also so ganz leicht
rosa und damit mache ich jetzt
zuallererst die unterste etage fertig
und zwar nehme ich mir jetzt erstmal für
die oberfläche so ein bisschen vom band
rollen auf ein bisschen becker stärker
aus zum thema am allerbesten also kein
fall bekannt stärke ist ja immer am
besten geeignet und da die oberfläche
jetzt trocken ist durch durch gleich
nicht wundern wenn ich da ein bisschen
back trends bei obendrüber macht dann
kann der fondant ein bisschen besser
haften
[Musik]
so für die röschen werde ich jetzt den
fondant ganz dünn ausrollen und dann
kleine kreise ausstechen und
anschließend nimmt er euch ein beutel
und eine art schaumstoff platte und
könnte diesen kreis noch mal richtig aus
dünnen damit er schön filigran und jetzt
meine freundin ist das ist super easy
sieht aber total süß aus wir verhalten
uns einmal in der mitte das zeigt ihr
euch gleich auch noch aus der nähe und
dann fällt müssen noch mal in der mitte
und erhalten so etwas hier eine rutsche
und die können wir dann ganz einfach an
die torte antje mit ein bisschen zucker
kleber und die hält dann auch wie von
allein habe ich gar keine sorgen machen
und das mache ich es einfach mit der
ganzen ort also mit dem ganzen land
[Musik]
sondern jetzt bin ich fertig mit dem
unteren teil der dort also die rüschen
finde ich schon richtig süß und das
ganze hat auch ziemlich lange gedauert
als ich saß jetzt ungefähr dreieinhalb
bis vier stunden brennen das müsst ihr
euch auf jeden fall auch ein teilen an
zeit die anderen zwei etagen gehen dafür
ein bisschen schneller
aber es ist mir jetzt zu spät wir haben
jetzt 23 geht es gleich es geht erstmal
natürlich die aufräum- und dann schlafen
dann sehen wir uns morgen wieder
[Musik]
so meine lieben einen tag später habe
ich die anderen zwei dort mit von land
überzogen die einer also die mittlere
torte
da habe ich ganz hell creme karmann vom
band genommen bzw weißen einfach
eingefärbt und beim anderen also bei der
anderen etage habe ich einmal musste
rein gemacht und zwar habe ich ganz
einfach den hell cremefarbenen fondant
genommen den hatte ich ja vorher
eingefärbt habe ganz viel übrig gehabt
und da so ein bisschen rosa
lebensmittelfarbe rhein geben und dann
kneten und dann erhaltet ihr automatisch
diese schöne mama muster und jetzt bin
ich so weit dass ich alle drei etagen
ineinander zusammenstecken und damit das
auch schön stabil gelingt müsst ihr so
ein paar sachen beachten zum einen
brauchen wir zum stabilisieren entweder
nimmt dicke strohhalme oder ich habe
jetzt hier einmal so ein rohr dass es
extra für torten gedacht das gebe ich
hier bei mir in die mitte ich stecke das
jetzt auch direkt rein ich demonstriere
euch das sofort so einmal rein stecken
in der mitte und dann markiert ihr euch
hier das stück zieht es wieder raus und
so und schneidet dann einmal ab und das
gleiche mache ich mit cake pops
stühlchen da könnt ihr wie gesagt auch
strohhalme nehmen und da gebe ich dann
fünf bis sechs einmal außen an den rand
damit ihr eben richtig schön ist so eine
stabile oberfläche habt und das muss
auch alles gleich lang sein damit es
schön ebenmäßig ist und eben nicht
schief
[Musik]
sobald ihr den stab und auch die kickbox
studie dann in die torte gesteckt habt
kommt einfach noch ein bisschen nach
oben drauf das ist wie so eine art
superkleber er klebt wirklich beide
etagen richtig fest zusammen und ihr
habt die möglichkeit dann noch ein
bisschen zurecht zu rücken
das gleiche macht ihr dann auch mit der
obersten etage und dann wird irgendwann
richtig richtig fest und so
transportiere ich die auch also gleich
im auto haben sie hoffentlich geht das
gut im kiki mobil schaffen wir schon
irgendwie gefällt einfach richtig
langsam und ein klima sehen und jetzt
fehlt noch so ein bisschen dieser
abschluss weil so sieht so ein bisschen
nackig aus und ich mache jetzt hier
erstmal zwischen dritte und zweite etage
einfach erst mal so eine band und dann
so ein schleifchen das zeige ich euch es
geht auch super easy
[Musik]
die mittlere torte dekoriere ich jetzt
mit blattgold keine sorge ist kein
echtes blattgold das ist einfach nur
dekoration und das ist super easy ihr
nimmt sich jetzt einfach einen
flugfähigen pinsel und befeuchtet den
ganz wenig bevor ich jetzt erst dem
fondant ganz wenig auch nur gibt dann
das blatt gut drauf und geht danach mit
dem pinsel dran und das klebt und hält
wie von alleine und das ist wirklich so
einfach wie es aussieht sollte jetzt
hier schon erledigt dann habe ich den
abschluss für die oberste etage gemacht
ganz einfach zwei stränge miteinander
verwirbelt und einmal dran geklebt immer
etwas zucker kleber oder ihr könnt auch
wasser nehmen zum befestigen und jetzt
fehlt im prinzip nur noch so ein
bisschen deko hier oben ich habe noch
einmal einen cache top mit dem namen des
babys das bekomme ich aber gleich erst
das kommt erst im saal dran und jetzt
kommen elcom die rosen zum einsatz ich
habe mich auch an der deko im saal
orientiert sind im saal gefeiert und es
werden solche rosen gab es extra
nachgefragt und deswegen habe ich jetzt
hier ganz einfach so ein bisschen
strohhalm bisschen diese dicken einfach
hier rein also hier drauf tun und dann
in die torte stecken und so kommt die
rose auch nicht in berührung mit der
torte und vor dem verzehr ganz einfach
entfernen und ein bisschen schleierkraut
habe ich auch noch da
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich auch diesen kleinen süßen
teddybären obendrauf gesetzt und da habe
ich für euch so ein extra tutorial
gedreht weil ich dachte das ganze
interessant
wir haben auf der suche ist nach fondant
bern dann kann man auf dieses video
immer zurückgreifen verlinke ich in die
video beschreibung und ich finde wenn
der bär nicht drauf welche weise dies
aufgefallen wenn der nicht darauf wer
dann könnte es auch als
junggesellenabschied verlobungs torte
durchgehend hochzeitstorte muss ja auch
nicht bereit so richtig süß na also ja
da steckt viel arbeit drin viel liebe
und ich hoffe dass ihr sie jetzt nach
macht oder als inspiration nimmt also
die einzelnen etagen könnte ja auch ganz
einfach variieren nur die unterste
machen nur die mittlere nur die oberste
ganze ihr möchtet ich wünsche euch jetzt
ganz viel freude beim nachmachen tut mir
eingefallen und gibt diesen wieder ein
dörfchen nach oben wenn es euch gefallen
hat und abonniert natürlich kostenlos
main kanal dann verpasst ihren solche
coolen torten auch nicht mehr
wir haben wir hier auf gigs kitchen das
große backen und auch manchmal das große
kochen und daher bin ich froh dass ihr
bis zum ende dabei geblieben seid und
wir lesen und in den kommentaren und
schreiben miteinander und bis zum
nächsten mal auf die hieß kitchen
ja ich finde die auch richtig ist
[Musik]